everybody happy first of all
congratulations on this wild success of
this show can you take people who are
not familiar with it how it started and
how its evolved sure I can probably take
that the show started quite a few years
ago actually in Chicago it started in
2017 yeah we went into workshops and we
were working with some amazing female
writers there and we put the show up in
Chicago first and then it went so well
there that we decided to bring it up
north to here in Toronto oftentimes when
you get into something like this when
you sit down and you're like what are we
gonna do starts off with what do we want
to say and what did you want to say
absolutely like with any sketch show
what we want to do is hold up a mirror
to the world yeah and everything that's
happening around us but the really
interesting thing with this show is we
wanted to put that through the female
gaze and really have a show that was
created by women to be honest it's still
for everyone I always say that by women
for everyone but we were looking for
those authentic female stories from
those authentic female voices and what
did you guys find when you started sort
of going through the stories I think
first of all just being in a sketch
production with a full female crew yeah
was amazing to me because having been in
comedy now for around 15 years often
you're the only woman in the room or
that's certainly how it was when I
started comedy so to be in a production
that's all women it's just it's it's so
fun so for me that was definitely
something that right off the bat I was
just like this is amazing and this never
or it doesn't happen very often I
imagine that the content then becomes
endless at some point where you're like
there's infinite stories let's true of
art in general right sure we can do the
same sketch that's about a couple in a
relationship but what makes it different
is now we have two females in a queer
relationship and that's really no
different from a man and a woman other
than fact that you have two completely
new points of views that you're bringing
to the table and that you're showing
your audience and now instead of having
the heterosexual couples being like
that's us you've got the baby so you're
able to show a lot more people
themselves on this on the stage yeah and
what do people get out of what do what
are people expecting when
they go in because I know especially
with this stuff and what this company is
known for is people love to be surprised
so what are the surprises like what do
you what have you been hearing from
audiences where the like man I wasn't
expecting that or whoa I think I think
we get a lot of people coming in
thinking oh it's gonna be a chick show
or all just about like your period and I
think they're incredibly surprised by
just how relatable and human it is and
just how ridiculously funny and
accessible it is to everyone I think
they're like oh oh there's like no
period stuff in there so congratulations
on the Canadian Comedy Award win for
best live ensemble like I mean talk me
through this here at that because that
is you know when you set out to do stuff
nobody says they get into art for awards
but then when everybody wins in a word
they're like what was that moment like
for for you guys oh it's thrilling yeah
yeah I mean this is an incredible group
of people that we get to work with and
we worked so hard and like Kirsten said
it's unusual and it hopefully will
become usual but for us I think it was a
very unique experience yeah
and part of like our rehearsal process
how we all took care of each other I had
a brand new tiny little baby and
everyone was like constantly holding and
taking care of him as though I never
needed to ask for a single hand at all
like I think it might have just my
partner and said like wonderful this
group is is incredible we support each
other we all have so many different
skills and talents and I think we all
like really bring out the best in each
other so it was it was an incredible
thrill to be like yes
we're amazing together that it's live
Ensemble is really quite flattering it
just shows that we all get along so well
on stage and off as well and so much of
what is required of the people who are
involved in second city is trusts when
did you all realize that this was a
group that you could all trust each
other
I mean from yep for me personally like I
was new kind of newer to second city and
I felt almost immediately I think one
day Paloma and I hugged and it was like
wow we like just like this instant
connection of all these incredible
people and it's the first time in a long
time where I found an entire cast has
gotten along so well and just you can
feel it backstage we're always joking
with each other and always having just
like the best time and you can see that
on stage and that's a comment that I
frequently get where people are like it
really seems like you truly enjoy each
other and I think that's incredibly
important yeah it absolutely is I mean
from a director's point of view I could
tell on day one you're asking people to
go to the moon and sketch you're asking
people to literally go to the absurd
someone in this chair beside me plays a
Tyrannosaurus Rex that can seem really
wild but the trust that they give over
they're gonna you're gonna fall into it
dive right into the deep end and with
open minds and open hearts and the
audience feels that and I felt it right
on day one and when you start hearing
the reviews when you're like wow people
are really loving what we're doing right
now what's that like when they just
start pouring in people are starved
first stories just from different
sources yeah Anne was talking about it
so nice for other people to see their
life on stage and not always represented
through just like a white male
perspective and that's this is a
refreshing take and we're speaking
powerfully and enthusiastically about
things that are important to us as
people and I think it's Universal in a
lot of ways so men are identifying with
it
all kinds of people who are possibly
marginalized people were all like yes
thank you for telling this story and now
it's kind of opening the gates for more
and more different storytellers which is
what this world so much of this seems
specific to 2019 yeah I mean there's
something about this time right now
where people are like this is needed it
was always interesting and fun yeah but
it's like this kind of thing is needed
yeah I think it's like you grow up I
feel about myself it's like I grew up
reading stories watching movies where
the center
character is a white sis hetero man and
so now it's kind of like okay something
else please and it's something that
feels like is being demanded in a way
that everyone was kind of like that
would be nice if that happened but in
2019 it's kind of like nope now it has
to happen and that's really refreshing
totally we love those great reviews
they're awesome and they make us feel
very nice we love the awards but with
this show in particular and you've hit
it with the 2019 effect it's talking to
the audience members after the show and
how it has deeply affected them and
either it's someone saying I saw you on
stage and so now I can see myself on
stage maybe a door has been open to me
and talking about listen we're seeing
women's rights come under attack in the
States right now and we have material
that deals with that and the audiences
are incredibly appreciate of it and it's
a catharsis and that's this amazing
comedic catharsis that also feels
empowering and so it does really feel
like now is the time and you're heading
off to Just for Laughs when you change
it up because it is just for Laughs it
yes laughs is that people come in and
they're very specific to just for laughs
like it's its own thing it's different
than any other sort of show that you can
tour around right so what's the plan for
Just for Laughs I can't speak to that
absolutely keep the route in the heart
of the show and the energy of the show
absolutely we'll update some things to
be Montreal specific Quebec specific and
as well with any satire show you're
always looking to keep it as topical and
of the now impossible
so as the news cycle changes so do those
small details within our show and when
you find out people like Colin Mochrie
you're fans of this and like what it
would I mean I know again it's not the
design of this but when that stuff
starts to happen there does you know do
you at this point say oK we've got a
good show let's just sort of roll with
this or at that point when you start
realizing that people are loving it
you're like how can we evolve are you in
a constant state of change with this I
mean for our show we have to
keep it the same because that's the run
of the show as it is with any theatrical
release but we all knew as soon as we
went through the script and read it out
loud the first time we knew we had a
really special show the first time
around and this time around and to have
the accolades and to have and to see
people like Colin Mochrie and our
audience which he frequents I think
you've seen the show on your own time
it means the world because it means that
we have a really good like we've got our
our fingers on the pulse we know what's
good we know it's funny and the audience
can see that too and for them to
appreciate it as much as we do is so
meaningful because the show is very
special to us and we would love to share
that joy and that pain sure that comes
with seeing some of the stuff that you'd
get to see but also with the laughs and
laughter is the best thing you can share
and that's what we need more of in this
world right now and it's such a
privilege to get to share that with the
audience I'm with the cast and I feel
like Toronto it has such a beautiful
comedy community and that we really
support each other and there's been so
many shows like this coming out in 2019
or even festivals like I think of the
black and funny festival that Coco
galore does and that's something that's
so unique and I think has a lot of
support from the community and then
Trish and I work on a show called a
sketch comedy extravaganza eleganza
that's all queer sketch and I think that
the producer who put that together Tom
Hern was literally inspired by she the
people he saw that showed he's like look
at this show of all women I want to do
that for the queers and then we did it
and it's been amazing and I was just
gonna say to you back to your point of
evolving the show is also written in a
way that there's improv in some parts so
we can very much stay in the moment and
refer to what's happening in the now and
it changes from show to show so that's
also fun and I cannot thank you all
enough for coming and congratulations
with everything good luck at Montreal
you